welcome back we're doing problem number
ten and i just drew the figure they said
a right circular cylinder
with radius five radius five and height
four
has volume v so what's the volume of
this you volume of a cylinder they give
you the formula actually but it's just
the area of the base or the area of the
the top of the cylinder times its height
so it's
pi r squared so where the radius is 5 so
it's pi
times 25 5 squared
times the height times four so v is
equal to 100 pi
fair enough
then they say
in terms of v what is the volume of a
right circular cinder with radius 5 and
height
eight
oh you see i didn't even have to do all
this because now this new cylinder this
new cylinder is
just like this cylinder right but
instead of having height four it has
height eight
see i didn't even have to know that
formula oh my god no i
i wanted to do a draw
needle ellipse
so this new cylinder looks something
like this although it's i'm not drawing
it really to scale but i think you get
the point
the new cylinder you can kind of just
so the new cylinder
has height eight
so what the new cylinder is twice the
size of the of the previous cylinder
right the previous cylinder had height
four radius 5 this new cylinder has
radius 5 height 8. so the new cylinder
is going to be twice the volume right
the y the volume for this is v so the
volume for the new one is is twice as
high so it's going to have twice the
volume so it's 2v
so it's answer is b
you didn't even have to know all this
you can go on the wrong track very
quickly
although if you did it that way you
could you know you'd get the right
answer
problem number eleven
if k n and r are integers let k
so k
be defined
okay so let k
k
diamond
nr
be defined to be true only if
so k diamond
is true
true
if
n is less than k which is less than r
then they tell us that minus 2
diamond
minus 2 diamond
n 0
is true
which of the following could be a
possible value of n
so let's just translate this into this
world right so this is true
at minus 2 diamond n 0 is true so that
means so we just pattern match right k
is minus 2
n is n and r 0. so
that means that so our n
n is just n so that means n
is less than k
k is minus 2
which is less than our r our r is 0.
so n is less than -2 which is less than
zero this is kind of i mean obviously
minus two is less than zero
so what which of the following could be
a possible value of n so they give us
three choices one is
minus three
two is minus one and then three
is positive three
well which of these numbers is less than
negative two
positive three isn't negative one is
greater than negative two so all we're
left is choice one
not not too hard of a problem right
a it just looks complicated
your image
invert colors
problem 12.
if 20 of x is equal to 80 of y so i
immediately my brain converts that to
decimals so twenty percent of x is equal
to
eighty percent of y
which of the following expresses y in
terms of x so we want y in terms of x so
let's solve for y we divide both sides
by 0.8 so y
is equal to
0.20
divided by 0.8
x right i just i switched them around
too right i switched to two sides but i
divided both sides by 0.8 that's all i
did
so y is equal to what's 0.2 over 0.8
well that's the same thing as 2 over 8
or 0.25 x
or y is
of x
and that is choice b
next problem
it's a very cold day today i'm i'm
my feet are cold and i should go to run
run run a hill or something all right
problem number 13.
if x y and z this seems familiar anyway
if x y and z are positive integers x y
and z are positive integers such the
value of
x plus y
x plus y is even
and the value of
x plus y
squared plus x plus z
is odd
which of the following is true and then
they're saying oh they give a bunch of
choices so what do we well this this is
actually quite quite interesting so
let's let's see what we can say
can we say that x is odd
x is odd that's choice a x is odd
if x plus y
is even
if x plus y is even
then x plus y squared will also be even
right
x plus y squared is also going to be
even so this is even
and then if but if this is even and then
this whole thing
is odd
if the whole thing is odd the only way
you can add
something to an even number and get an
odd number is if the thing you added was
odd right and you can think about that
so x plus z is odd
so we essentially know two things x plus
y is even
and we also know that x plus z is odd
right and how do we figure out x plus c
is odd because we know x plus y is even
x plus y squared must be e in and the
only way to get
to add something to something that's
even get an odd number is if that thing
you add is odd so we know that x plus z
is odd
this is interesting so
so so we know x plus y is even x plus z
is odd
so can do we know for sure that x is odd
well no x could be even x could be two
what you know y could be two
and uh
x could be two and z could be one so x
we don't know that x is odd
and then choice b says x is even well
not necessarily x could be odd x could
be one y could be one
x could be one here and z could be two
so
that all works so choice b doesn't work
either
now choices c and d look interesting if
z is even if z is even then x is odd
that is true because if we add these two
numbers and we get an odd number and we
know that z is even
if this number is even then this number
has to be odd and you can try it out
with numbers if you don't believe me
so c
is true
and we could go through the other ones
but you only have to pick one so c is
definitely true if z is even then x is
definitely odd because the only way to
add something to an even number an odd
number is if you get if you add it to an
odd number
let's do problem number 14 if i have
time
problem fourteen
zero is less than x which is less than
one
which of the following statements must
be true
statement one statement one is x squared
is greater than x cubed statement two
is
x is greater than x over two
the statement three says that x is
greater than
x to the third
so x is pretty much a fraction it's a
it's a positive fraction
less than one and you know what
let's just try out a number let's just
try out x is equal to one-half and that
will simplify things because really all
the fractions between zero and one have
the same properties when you take the
exponents so let's see is this true
one-half squared is one-fourth
one-fourth is greater than
one-eighth well yeah sure that's true
is one-half
greater than
one-fourth
right one-half divided by two is
well sure
that's true
and finally is one half
greater than one half to the third
sure one half to the third is one eighth
so one
one half is definitely greater than one
half to the third right and they're all
positive numbers so all three of them
are true so it's choice
e
and that's all the time i have in this
video i will do problem 15 in the next
video see you soon